JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello, and
welcome to Google Developers
Live.
We have an exciting
show for you today.
Today we'll talk about graph
processing and Freebase RDF
dumps.
This is the first in a series of
episodes where we'll introduce
technology you might find
useful for your applications.
Let me first introduce
our guests and hosts.
My name Jarek Wilkiewicz, I'm
based here in Mountain View.
On the Hangout,
we have our guests
from Sindice Technologies,
Giovanni Tummarello
and Harish Kumar.
How are you doing, guys?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO: Hi, guys.
HARISH KUMAR: Hi, fine.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Joining
us live from Ireland.
And then from London,
we have Dan Brickley.
How are you doing, Dan?
DAN BRICKLEY: Hi, guys.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Well, let's get into it.
Giovanni, tell me a
little more about what
is it that your company does.
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
Well, thanks.
Our company starts from--
it's a university spin-off,
but we've been around for
a couple of years now.
And the idea is this.
We have been trained, we've been
working on very large knowledge
graphs.
Something originally
referred to as semantic web,
like the whole
web as a database.
And now that technology
takes the big data
and Knowledge Graph
technology, RDF,
can be delivered
into Enterprises.
And there's a lot
of use for this.
So the company is about
Enterprise Knowledge Graph,
being able to give to companies
what Google has, what Facebook
is working on, and Yahoo
and the other guys.
Now also other companies
can have it in enterprises.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And fundamentally,
what is the problem
that you're trying to solve?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
Well, traditionally,
when you think about
knowledge-- don't
think about the classic
computer science graph
where you want to cross a bridge
or seven bridges or whatever.
Think about knowledge.
In general, it's entities
and relationships.
You have people, and
you have products,
and you want to connect
people with their purchases
and their products, et cetera.
So typically, you think
in terms of silos,
since in the database,
you have tables,
and you predefine what
the properties are.
And off you go.
And you're OK, because
you know your domain.
And those are the information
you know about things
when you write your application.
What happens is we live in
a very exciting era where
you might learn a lot.
The web, so many databases
are popping around.
You might learn a lot
about a single person,
like 1,000 facts.
And you know nothing
about the others.
And therefore you
would like to store all
that because it could be useful.
You could use this for
your recommendation,
for your customer
relationship management.
You want to store that.
And you want to store anything
about this other record
that you have.
So you have-- you
know, you don't
want to create 1,000 different
columns in your database.
So what happens is
this sort of scenario,
it's a scenario where it looks
like a graph, in a sense.
It's not anymore
columns, orderly,
but it's more like a
graph, a knowledge graph.
Which is very similar to
what you have in Freebase.
Which, indeed, has
1,000 of different kinds
of pieces of information.
And that is very useful
in a lot of sectors
where you're not happy with
predefining your stuff a
priori.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So just
to try to summarize it.
So the reason why
this is important
is because there's a
class of applications
that will benefit from this
type of data representation.
Is that pretty much
what it is about?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO: Oh,
certainly there is a class.
I mean, think of application
in a lot of sectors,
from health care, life
sciences, which is typical.
There's so many databases
popping up here and there
on this topic.
You might never know where
to connect your [INAUDIBLE].
So you want to get it and
connect it and hang it
to your Knowledge Graph,
your vertexes of information.
You don't want to lose it.
To consumer space,
obviously there's
so much information about
each one or whatever.
Needless to say, in technical
publishing or defense
or [INAUDIBLE] application
where-- let alone
financials, for example-- where
oh, you want to keep it all.
And you want to
learn how to use it.
You want to be able to
experiment in new ways
to use it.
So definitely very,
very applicable.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So I understand Harish is
going to show us a demo
to help us understand how
this all fits together
and to help us visualize it.
So should we hand
it over to Harish
now so he could
walk us through it?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
Yeah, just a second just
to give an introduction.
Yes, Harish has been working
on our product, [? officer ?]
has been working on what
today we're releasing,
which is the Freebase
SindiceTech distribution.
And basically the idea is to
make it much, much simpler
for developers to
quickly spin something
in the cloud-- in fact, we're
using Google Cloud today--
to have your own Freebase.
Your own Freebase,
it's your own,
it's in your machine
already preloaded.
You can launch queries
as much as you want.
You can see it and explore it.
And it's not just the
data, but it's also
a set of tools to help
understand the data.
We precompute certain
analytics, for example.
We compute all the analytics.
And you get certain
tools, which are
based on the analytics, that
allow you to see the schema
and to get very nice
suggestions helping you
how to do the query.
And that is a distribution.
Full distribution will come.
Today we have this
first distribution.
Next one, likely
next month, will also
have the search capabilities.
And we'll go on with that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, great.
So someone who uses the
Google Compute Engine
will be able to instantiate
this image and experiment
with the data.
And that has the Freebase
RDF dump already included.
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
Yeah, you get-- really,
you get your own Freebase,
just by spinning up
the machine plus
everything else.
And there is a
specialized database
for RDF already preloaded,
with your tools, open source.
Thanks, guys, they
have been helping us.
And off we go with
the demonstrations.
HARISH KUMAR: As
Giovanni was saying,
the Sindice Freebase
distribution
allows you to get
quickly started
with using the Freebase dump.
The distribution is packaged as
a machine image for the Google
Compute Engine.
You can use this to create
your own personal instance
of the dump.
Once you have your
own private dump,
you could mix your own
data with the Freebase data
and query it all together.
So when you
instantiate the image,
you should see this picture.
Besides the triple store
that has been preloaded
with the Freebase data, you'll
also get a set of useful tools
for working with this data.
So one of the first
tools that we will see
is the data types explorer.
If you want to use
Freebase effectively,
you need to understand what
are the types of data that
are present and the instance
counts for these types.
So if you see here, you'll
see the various types.
You'll see music.release_track,
music.recording,
and so on, so forth.
So these are the types.
You have people.person here.
So if you expand this,
you will see other types
related to people.person.
So this is a cluster
which contains
people.person type and
the book.author type.
And you have 500,000
plus instances of it.
So these two columns,
the first column
gives you all the
instances which
have both these types,
people.person and book.author.
Whereas the second column gives
you the count of instances
that only have these two types.
If you have types
other than these two,
they will be added up to
this particular number.
So this is a very
useful way to understand
what are the various
types out there,
and how they're
clustered together.
Another useful visualization
of this very data is the graph.
So what you see
here, for instance,
is all the types
that you saw there.
Each node represents a cluster.
A cluster is nothing but
a collection of types.
So if you hover over
it, you'll see the types
on the right hand side.
And the green ones
are the clusters
with just a single type.
So if you hover over
this green type,
you'll see it's people.person
with the same count.
So if you type in people.person
here, just select that.
You will see in red all
of the clusters that
have people.person as
part of that cluster.
So if you look at this
cluster, for instance, that
people.person, and
then you'll see
a range of other
additional types.
And what you'll
notice is that there's
a huge number of
clusters or types
which basically have
people.person type.
Whereas you have
much more smaller
clusters in the
surrounding data.
So this is useful
to understand when
you want to-- if
you wanted to decide
how do you want to
use Freebase data.
So the final tool that
I'm going to show you
is the SPARQL editor.
So this is the interface
to the Virtuoso endpoint.
The thing is that
triple stores, you
need to know the URIs of the
various types and predicates
to be able to
formulate the queries.
What SparQLed
allows you to do is
to get auto-citations
for these URIs
so that you could formulate
these queries very easily.
So let me just show you how.
So let's say we want to find
some information about films.
So you say F. And you want to
extract the type of the film.
So you type in film.
And you press Control-Tab.
And it shows you a
bunch of auto-citations.
So this is the URI
for the film type.
So there you go.
And now you want to pull out
some additional properties
of the film.
Say you want the
label of the film.
So you type in label.
And it fills out
the appropriate URI.
And you can put in FL.
And now you'll want maybe
some additional information
about the film, let's
say the release date.
So you say release.
And you can see that the film
initial release date appears.
So let me try it again.
So there you go.
So that's it.
So click Send.
And you see the data here.
So you can see some
duplicate entries.
This is because of the
different languages.
You can filter them
out very easily.
You can just specify a filter
clause, filter on the language,
and that should do the trick.
So you can see that all
the labels are in English.
So this is basically
how you can go
about querying the
[INAUDIBLE] very
easily with the aid
of the auto-citations.
Incidentally,
though, the citations
are powered by the summary
that was mentioned earlier.
The summary is computed using
Sindice Analytics, which
is a Hadoop-based
application for computing
aggregates on the data in terms
of how many instances are there
of a particular type, how
many properties are there
of a particular type,
and so on and so forth.
And that is what powers
the auto-citations here.
So that was just
a quick overview
of the applications
that are packaged
as part of our distribution.
We will be including
instructions
as to how you could
create your own instance.
We encourage you to
try it out yourself
and let us know what
you think about it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Well, thank you for
running this for us.
It's very interesting.
I know Dan had some questions
about the technical aspects
of down the line
architecture and so forth.
So I'll hand it over to Dan now.
DAN BRICKLEY: Hi, guys.
So I've got a diagram
here from you.
I'm not sure if people
can see it on the screen.
But can you talk us through
how the pieces of the system
fit together, like where
Sindice plugs into Virtuoso
and where that plugs into Cloud.
Give us a kind of workflow
architecture picture.
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
The new thing here
is that traditionally,
what you would
do when you're integrating
data, you would do ETL, right?
So you'd spend a lot
of time extracting,
then understanding the data.
And then when you
understand it, you
can transform it and then
load it into a production ETL.
And that is very time-consuming.
So what happens when instead
of 10 tables or 15 tables,
you have potentially 1,000
or 15,000 like in Freebase?
I mean, you'd be
completely lost.
So you need a new step here.
Which we provide with this
tool, which RDF provides
and all the tools
that we put together,
is the exploration step.
So in other words, as
Harish was saying, but there
are other tools in
the distribution
which are quite interesting.
And you should check them out.
You get tools to
explore the data.
It's what some people call pay
as you go data integration.
In other words, you
put it together.
And you can already
query it with SPARQL,
which is really flexible.
Might not be fast for
production-grade right
away in SPARQL.
So you might still need to
load it into NoSQL systems
or into specific indexes.
And we have one specifically
about a semi-structured
information called SIREn,
which is an extension of Solr
specifically for richly
structured information.
We'll talk about it
next time if possible.
You might still load it
into specific systems.
But right away you
get the full power
of a really powerful
query language.
And you get tools that
allow you exploration.
So it's much more interactive,
much more explorative.
You get stuff right from
the beginning, more or less.
DAN BRICKLEY: So
maybe this question
is going to be a
little unfair, given
that it's such a general
purpose architecture,
but can you say
a little bit more
about the kind of
applications you anticipate
people building on top of this?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
What usually happens
is you want to build a
Knowledge Graph for a company.
An example is a Knowledge Graph
for a company, whatever company
it might be-- you start
with your relational data.
And you put it in the graph.
And then what happens
is you find out
there is this beautiful
data set that's
like Freebase, for example.
Or others, it could be whatever.
And you basically align it and
put it together with your data.
Which is what you can do in
the distribution, for example.
At that point, here you
have a very rich cloud.
And you can already query
from one concept to another.
But then you can go on, and if
you have unstructured content,
like [INAUDIBLE] text or
technical content is amazing,
you can extract concepts,
relationships between concepts,
or you might have data tables.
That also can go into a
Knowledge Graph, which
is your domain-specific
Knowledge Graph,
your Enterprise Knowledge Graph.
And then even your
customer data,
so that you can have
vertical products
specific for your customers.
And ontologies, [? except ?]
ontologies are basically rich
taxonomies.
And you can do the
reasoning and rules
and enhance it even more
to ultimately basically be
able to leverage all this
information together.
How do you leverage?
What do you do with it?
Well, you do really
interesting things.
You do domain-specific
applications,
you do search which is much
more advanced than what
you could do before.
You can do relational
browsing in a way
that basically-- I
wouldn't be saying
it's for everything, right?
I wouldn't be saying
it's for everything.
And for example, we were talking
to some people in the consumer
banking space.
And they said well, no.
Because we know everything.
That's how banking works.
And we don't need to
explore data that much.
We might need to explore
numbers, but not types
of data, not new kinds of data.
So no, not for consumer banking.
But for analysts, for example,
in the financial sector
or whatever, that's
a different story.
They want to put a lot of new
dots together all the time.
And this is the most
agile infrastructure
that you can build.
DAN BRICKLEY: Thanks.
Can you tell us a
little bit about the way
the RDF data dumps from Freebase
fit into this architecture?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
Well, Freebase
is an amazing resource.
Let's say that
you're doing anything
that has to do with a consumer.
You really want to
be leveraging that.
You want to be able to say,
well, I'm selling this record.
But because this record was
awarded this thing last week,
you might want it.
And that would show
it in Freebase,
that you might want put it on
the homepage or recommend it.
So any sort of recommendation,
matching, grouping
and clustering of
your content, done
in a very rich way
across the graph.
Freebase is the perfect
crystallization point
for that sort of knowledge.
It definitely doesn't
contain everything.
You might want to
enrich it even more.
You might want to put your
secret sauce of data inside.
But it's a fantastic resource.
DAN BRICKLEY: Can you
tell us a little bit more
about your use of SPARQL?
And in particular, SPARQL is
great with financial data.
But the more data
you have, the more
sources you mix,
the messier it gets.
How do you deal with SPARQL
robustly with real-world data?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
Most definitely.
It's not like [? two ?]
different people have
been working on
this RDF [INAUDIBLE]
for a very long time.
And we're not the most-- we're
not going to tell you, oh, you
should throw away everything
else, and you should use this.
No, you should use this
when it makes sense.
When you have such a
richness of information
that you're really enjoying
having this very powerful tool.
Because otherwise, then
this could be overwhelming.
So there's no way out.
The sooner you clean
your data, the better.
So in other words--
Freebase had this refine,
which then was Google Refine
and now is OpenRefine.
That's an amazing tool
to start, that's great.
So you avoid the messiness
by starting with something
like that from the beginning.
Then there's a plug-in
that writes to RDF.
So you can get OpenRefine,
get your table.
Try to align it, even
through Freebase.
Dump it directly in the SPARQL
endpoint in this distribution.
And you'll be able to
query ready with Freebase.
So try it, when you are in
SPARQL already because you
already loaded everything there.
SPARQL is not great
for modifying stuff,
it's mostly for querying.
So what you do,
however, is you have
one of the most
flexible languages
to try to still do a query that
will fit the pieces together.
You still would
be able to do it.
And once you understand how the
pieces would piece together,
then you will probably
transform and actually
make them fit better
in the loading phase.
That's more or less
an intrinsic process.
HARISH KUMAR: And we
could say that SPARQL
is pretty well-suited for
the ad-hoc kind of querying
that you need to
do with dirty data.
So there's a good
fit, in a sense,
between SPARQL and data that is
incrementally being integrated.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
So for our audience
that would like to experiment
with this some more,
this is a lot of information
in today's session.
And a lot of the
terms might not be
familiar to people
new to the graph
processing, the whole very
rich semantic web community.
What's kind of the
next step for them?
What do they do next?
GIOVANNI TUMMARELLO:
Well, I'd say
first thing is
visit the website.
And visit Sindicetech/freebase,
sindicetech.com/freebase.
And then be able to get
some very easy instructions
to get their own Freebase and
be able to play with it right
away.
And then there is plenty of
tutorials on RDF and SPARQL.
It's a very mature
language, by the way.
It's not-- it's been there
for years and years and years.
And it's quite an
interesting functionalities.
And also we look forward
to helping people.
So just let us know.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Well, thank you very much
for putting it together.
And I'll make sure to check
out the image on Google Compute
Engine.
And then for those
of you watching,
thank you for your attention.
I would like to mention in
closing that Google Developer
Relations is hiring.
So if you're looking for
a career change in 2014,
check out
developers.google.com/jobs.
Thank you, Dan, for
staying up late in London.
Thank you, guys, for
joining us from Ireland.
And for those of you watching,
I will see you next time
on Google Developers Live.
Bye.